my heart is racing they're really really
gross really revolting they'll kill you
with one bite I hate spiders it's like
with a passion hi I'm Diana terranova
and I'm a live insect handler today
we're gonna be helping people get over
their fear of spiders this is real my
hands are shaking for real when we're
handling the spiders what we want to do
is I wanna be as quiet as possible
actually this is a juvenile since you
just got yourself soft right do they
smell fear does he know that I'm afraid
you're doing great hey you did this this
one right here is a Chilean red flame
door they're a tiny spider but they're
actually full growl oh why would you
torture it like that well this is kill
me if it bites me mmm oh hey you might
want to get yourself on Malta P doggy a
little hybrid but nature has created its
own hybrid arachnid in the web scorpion
it's like a cricket and a cockroach and
the scorpion with that tail almost looks
like a shrimp this is what Will Smith
killed him in and glass I'm saying to
get a little bit more relaxed didn't get
it closer yeah no I did it's still weird
looking and it feels weird and if I saw
this I still kind of want to kill it I'm
sorry
oh my gosh everybody should have one of
these they're the perfect present for
Christmas the Valentine's Day you name
it it's a Rose hair tarantula that have
enough vitamins and protein does she
don't you think it's like a new jewelry
statement yeah now put your other hand
again later bye-bye she's trying to give
my mouth but they do they all hang out
personally
I've held a snake I've jumped off cliffs
and this is still one of the scariest
things I've ever done in my entire life
I was like a species I'm like I like you
I appreciate you guys I like you from a
distance like I like my ex-boyfriends
from a distance
I'm definitely less scared of big
spiders I still don't really like small
spiders I guess am I gonna still run
away from them yes but will I be able to
not scream as loud maybe
[Music]